what's in store
[Music]
that's a clip from last night's very
special reunion performance by Roxy
music as they were inducted into the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame formed in
Britain in 1970 the band was highly
influential in the rock world adding
avant-garde elements of fashion and art
to their performances and paving the way
for bands like u2 the Talking Heads and
Duran Duran before the show I sat down
with lead singer Bryan Ferry at the
Lambs Club here in New York to talk
about the band's legacy with their blend
of glamour and art school eccentricities
Roxy Music the British band led by Bryan
Ferry would blur the boundaries of rock
music
did you have a sense of what sort of
sound you wanted to make I wanted to
explore different styles of music I
didn't really want any limitations star
wise it kind of ended up being a sort of
kind of a collage effect the English
magazine The Economist's recently called
them quite simply the greatest art rock
group Britain has produced this side of
the Beatles ferry grew up near Newcastle
in northern England where he delivered
newspapers and magazines as a boy and
now it just walked down the street
reading room avidly all these articles
about Charlie Parker and so on and
people these kind of Giants of music
coming through Newcastle where I had to
go and you buy my cheap ticket and some
sort of taking this music at my little
white trenchcoat I was really moved by
all that music and I just thought it was
marvelous you know and the feeling is
never really left Vienna fairy's father
took care of the horses in the coal
mines
yeah pulling the coal wagons and what a
job that mustered a very hard-working
guys I had this strong working-class
kind of effort work ethic and from a
from a young age did you think a career
in music was possible that oh not at all
never occurred to me
[Music]
ferry started writing songs while
studying art at the University of
Newcastle he met saxophonist and a makai
who introduced him to Brian Eno he'd man
the synthesizers while Paul Thompson
joined on drums and Phil Manzanera
on guitar amigo rocks again
[Music]
we surprised it how successful it was
anyway
yeah mais youngster she loved the we
their debut single Virginia plane
released in 1972 soared to number four
on the British charts
your look was as distinctive as your
sound
well they kind of experimented with that
too
we were kind of all all of us in the
band were quite shy sort of kind of
reserved characters and dressing up to
go on stage made it easy for us kind of
to step out of character
just being theatrical it was like
getting into a role or something it kind
of made it easier for us to perform but
in 1973 Brian Eno left the band going on
to collaborate with artists like David
Bowie and u2 he had a major turning
point when Brian left it happens on lots
of bands where people you know want to
go into other things and it's upset a
lot of people because they liked us
being together
[Music]
you know Roxy music would release eight
albums three went to number one in
Brittany but the US was harder to crack
[Music]
until their final album Avalon released
in 1982 would sell more than a million
copies in America
[Music]
Fairey disbanded the band after that
but continued a successful solo career
[Music]
recently his music has been used in
Babylon Berlin the German language
series on Netflix in a club scene ferry
himself appears singing his song
bittersweet German cabaret star as if it
had been done in a different age and I
found it quite interesting to approach
the songs from that different angle
last night Roxy Music finally made it
into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
inducted by Duran Duran a band they
greatly influenced I'm always proud to
say that without Roxy Music there really
would be no Duran Duran
[Music]
and ferry reunited with two of his
original Roxy bandmates Andi Makai and
Phil Manzanera that's probably the last
time we'll see Roxy music though I
should imagine so yeah so you better
make the most of it what a classic
yeah they sounded great last night and
he will be on tour performing Avalon
actually through the summer in the US so
that's something just look forward to
artists to the end yep